[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the zaniac on the
floor and this video we breaking down
Loki we going to die oh hey nice to meet
you we all going to die season 2 episode
2 is just dropped and it's packed with
Easter eggs hidden details and big
reveals for the future throughout this
video we're going to be going through it
scene by scene to talk about everything
in it all the things you miss yes you
and our theories for episode three heavy
spoilers ahead and if you enjoy the
breakdown then please smash the like
button and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns every week but the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into Loki don't overthink
[Music]
it now we begin in Chell London back in
1977 this is at the premiere of X5
zaniac who he learns became a big film
star 1977 was a massive year for movies
and this was of course when Star Wars
was dropped at that point it was the
biggest movie of all time with
Blockbusters becoming a major thing
after the release of Jaws that happened
2 years prior and we then saw an influx
of films that revolutionize Cinema to
the left on the news down we can see two
defunct papers with a messenger and
inquire about going out of business
least I think I tried Googling it I
couldn't find them so we're put we're
putting facts down like the truth and if
you don't like it mate is to be fair
there's probably much better breakdowns
out there now Loki instantly suspects
that Sylvia isn't here because he
believes that location too safe it
doesn't feel right I know but why it's
too safe it's not a war zone it's not an
apocalypse it's not her style in season
one she was of course hiding out of
apocalypses because changing things
wouldn't really make a difference this
was shown when Loki visited Pompei just
before the volcano erupted and wiped
everything out doing this meant that
nothing at these points really mattered
as it would all be a raise before it
could make an impact however as we see
syv is creating a life for herself and
doing this while off in a branch
timeline now as and Mobius walk towards
the cinema we can catch a Kingo poster
on the wall as we learn in eternals he's
created a film Dynasty in which he
becomes a big actor and then pretends to
be their son now as we get to the
premiere we see a poster for the movie
which actually has a lot going on with
it X5 is going under the name Brad wolf
who was the alter ego of zyak in the
comics that had Brad growing up in a
neglectful household but he Channel this
negativity into becoming an actor
starring a ziac this was a big monster
movie that's s on in costumes like the
classic Universal films things like The
Wolf Man and Frankenstein they become
legendary movies and Brad was expecting
the same stardom from this however when
he was in costume about to film a scene
an explosion caused him to mutate into
zaniac and become the character acting
out the movie script in real life he
ended up kidnapping women and carrying
out mass murders whilst also being
possessed by a demon ziac was stopped by
Thor and after being subdued he was then
arrested now we discover that the
Demonic entity had basically taken over
and this was controlling him and killing
all those people upon Wolf's death this
burst forth from his body and the TV
actually had to go back in time and stop
it now this isn't really in line with
that and instead X5 is just playing the
part without the other stuff involved
man's popularity is rising through the
roof though and we even seen the crowd
people holding up signs to marry them
last week there was a lot of talk about
how the TVA had taken away their lives
and there's the temptation to go out
there and live one this is Sam mobia
shuts down later on when he gets asked
about his jet ski lifestyle now as we
learn X5 was sent out undercover but in
the end he was tempted with having a
life come on Mobius you're going to ruin
my life here your life here making
something for himself he's now seen as a
superstar he's rumored to be hooking up
with Bridget BAU a former model from the
time who's also starred in a lot of
movies X5 is probably a bit of a
narcissist so all the stuff he's doing
now makes a lot of sense man even
painted X and5 on his gloves showing
that he wanted to stand out more than
anyone else mobus then says will there
be a zaniac too no sequel for the fans
in the comics we of course know they
never got to make one and due to what
happens here we know that won't be the
case either we then get the line now I
used to work with this guy which may be
riffing on this we know each other he's
a friend from work now X5 plays along at
first pretending he's glad to see them
but he then rushes out which leads into
a big chase forgot to say but I love
Loki 70 style Tu and outside we see B15
looking snazzy too grabbing his temp pad
this leads into a big chase with Loki
going through strand Lane which is an
important place in London this was the
center point for theater and musical
Halls during the 19th century and it
still retains some of these so it makes
sense why the premier is here X5 manages
to use a Time twist to get himself out
of there which are items we've seen in
the series before Loki ends up creating
an illusion that there's a crowd of
people and we get a hint to this being
magic due to the amount of people
changing when X5 first runs around the
corner there is a smaller crowd whereas
when he moves into it way more pop up
Loki also duplicates himself which is a
move that he did during the first
Avengers for crowd control growing his
horns in the shadows these of course
belong to his helmet and it sort of
gives the impression that he's a kind of
devil I have a theory that Loki will end
up taking over the position of he who
remains which is something I think the
series has been spelling out to us the
opening shot had him running in front of
the statue and he also referred to the
character as the devil you need to kill
the devil maybe he was Loki clearly has
his darkest ITB too which I think
highlights that he should take over he
knows that the war is coming and though
he thinks people should get free will he
did agree with what he who remains was
doing war and it's on its way and maybe
it's true everything he was doing the
prun it was about preventing more of him
there was no Simple Choice there was no
other way with it comes a cost and he
might be the only one who knows that so
in the end I think he'll take over this
is something that happened in the comics
too and during the young Loki Buck he
discovered the old division of him was
ruling over it all now the comics and
live action stuff is never one for one
but yet just something to think about
when going over the series now from here
we cut to the title sequence and huge
shout outs to Ryan ER last week for
going over what this scene signifies he
pointed out that almost all the letters
come from of the films that Loki is
featured in with there being the type
face for Thor Avengers Dark World
Ragnarok endgame and so on the letters
signify that we're dealing with a number
of different Lois but it's all black and
white in this to show they're still Loki
now if you're enjoying the breakdown and
want to support the channel we've got
some Loki inspired merch just below on
the Shelf at the bottom of the video we
also have aoka themed one that's going
to get vaulted soon a little Theory time
one so yeah check them out if you enjoy
the videos now back at the TVA they look
of x5's temp pad a little closer and see
that it's been modified taking it to OB
we catch him creating a way to fix the
loom which I think might lead into some
things happening next time I know some
of you don't like when we discussed
trailers early in the video though so
I'll save that for the end in case you
want to duck out giving them the
official handbook this is something you
also thre to Loki last week and we
learned that he wrote it himself he
created all the TVA gadgets too and I
actually feel like Obi may be a bigger
power in the show as we saw last time he
never got his memory wiped and this is
why he remembered m but Mobius didn't
remember him because he invented
everything that also means he invented
the temp pad which is the key to time
travel someone who could do this would
be extremely important to Kang and we
may even find out he had his hand in the
chair from Quantum Mania I feel like he
may be integral to the operation of the
TVA to the point that Kang couldn't
afford to wipe his memory wiping his
memory would remove all of his knowledge
and therefore he was kept in this state
thus he just had to be shuffled out the
way so he could fix stuff but was never
involved in the main things when you
think about it even stuff sent to him is
done directly through funnels and this
is in order to avoid any interaction he
just keeps working away doesn't sleep
and even the name Ora borus means a
snake eating its own tail which is a
cycle that's constantly going on this
could be seen as a self-destructive
cycle which may be represented in OB and
also the TVA we can also catch a little
mini alligator on his desk which could
be a nod to one of the lowkey variants
up with KC we can see a post when in the
background with this idea of them coming
from the truck last week we hear there's
lots of theories about what's going on
with raona and also get a confirm that
Miss minutes is down as we know though
she likely abandoned the TVA and though
we discovered that Ren Slayer deleted
all the evidence on her temp pad they
can track the last message during the
scene we also see Mobius desk which
makes her return from earlier in the
series this is where Loki first probably
talk with Miss minute and that actually
happened in season 1 episode 2 she was
able to dodge out the away and Loki
wondered whether she was a hologram or a
recording that knew the future clearly
she knew the way time was supposed to
play out though which was Miran he who
remains who was able to dodge selie
attacks now they learned Miss minutes
was the one who was working with Ren
Slayer which we saw playing out during
the season one finale when we first cut
to raona during the 7 Minute Mark of
that episode we could also catch that
her temp pad was downloading things on
the organization but I'm downloading the
files you need now this isn't what I
asked for I know but he thinks this will
be more useful I think raona then
traveled out of the place that Victor
timely is located out which we'll
probably see later on in the season
taking a shine to the temp pad Casey
starts to study it and we see as the
interrogation starts off with X5 he
knows their tactics though so it does
prove to be more than difficult now I
love the way the wall is orange and the
floor paneling is the same color as the
prison uniform gives such an awesome
color style to the scene and throughout
these episodes yeah the way they use
color is really well thought out X5 then
keeps correcting them that he's called
Brad and this shows he's really became
attached to his life he then rips into
Loki about how he's now a reformed
villain but all he ever does is make
things worse bringing up his mother Loki
inadvertently caused her death in th the
Dark World though this version hadn't
experienced that yet however he did see
it play out on the hollow projector in
episode one so was aware of what happens
with her you're a
villain you're good at it this kind of
pushes Loki into bringing out his darker
side which we see him leaning into more
later on in the episode there's
definitely this idea of both him and X5
playing up their dark sides and going
after what they want in the end might be
a reach here but early on at the
premiere we could see the tagline for
the zaniac post as saying no one can
escape his terrible craving for blood
this is something I feel thematically
runs throughout the episode with zaniac
even being a character that sort of
reflects Loki ziac was someone that
wanted to be a hero but they gave into
their dark side due to the demon that
was inside of them Loki has this darker
side too and though he's trying to be a
hero he has this other side that's
constantly pulling him back X5 very much
is also a reflection of Loki as well and
in a lot of ways he's sort of let's say
the less Charming side of his
personality X5 is selfish and out for
his own ends which is also something
that Loki was after too he put his own
feelings above the TVA and wants the
fame acceptance and notoriety that comes
with it this is something at Loki was
after two with him going against his
family and Asgard to achieve his own
thing either way both ended up in a
jumpsuit but they were still desperate
to kind of claw their way back now
against the walls we also see these
pipes and hoses leading into other areas
of the TVA but these create linear
looking structures hanging off the sets
you might have noticed throughout the
episode that there's lots of pipes and
lines going off into other things which
I sort of think dramatically creates the
idea of timelines huge shout out to our
IMT who noticed this last week after
pointing out the funnels above Obie's
head somewhat resembles the timelines
and the temporal Loom these pipes are
all getting collected into one place
which then goes to Obie who fixes it
looking at the show as a whole these
strands are all connecting together on
the time Loom which Obie's pulling
together and then also fixing again I
feel like he may be way more important
than we know and this series might even
end up being about him in the same way
that the first one was more about Sylvie
now Mia says Brad Brad who had sh
this and even promises to return him to
the timeline so he can continue being a
star X5 points out that Fallas the TVA
and asks who he really is on the
timeline planning the idea in his head I
do think that we will eventually see
mes I'll talk about this in the trailer
section part of the video though but he
clearly touches on a nerve which makes
him punch him mbius has lost it so much
he even questions who's following who
and we watch as they come down with some
key lime pie there not anyone here who
serves it and you the name being automat
I think this is just created and cloned
the pies themselves could even signify
the variance and how they're all kind of
similar but not exactly alike again
going into the set design we have here
everything's either orange or lime green
color whether it's the crust the ceiling
the clock of the floors it's all sort of
divided up into these two tones this
somewhat Siz in aloki himself with his
colors also being shades of these two
also looking at the Clark hanging from
the roof there's not actually any way to
tell what the time is the several hands
all just pointing out randomly with
there not really being any time in the
TVA Loki opens up about his anger and
talks about how he invaded New York and
then tried to use the Mind Stone on Tony
he admits he lost it and tried to kill
Tony by throwing him out the window
which both happened during the Avengers
also to this version of Loki that
happened like a week ago with a escaping
during endgame and then going to the TVA
man then got to he who remains within a
couple of days and I think to him the
Avengers was probably just last week
better times it was and both the Marvel
and real life now they have a heart to
heart about Mobius and the life he was
supposed to live saying that this is in
fact his we get it cleared up that they
now know they were kidnapped variant
that were drafted into this much in the
same way Loki was in season 1 I think
what Loki will do as a whole is show us
the creation of the TVA and its fall
which we've already seen due to he who
remains I'm guessing Victor timely will
show its beginnings and then we'll spend
most of our time here when the
organization started to crumble cutting
to the end of time I feel like the
Castle's the last known headquarters
without Rock being all that exists of
the organization Mt last week did a big
video breaking down all the connections
to black holes which appeared in the
credits and the lines of dialogue he
theorize that we actually see the TVA
located in its own black hole which will
exist at the end of time until there's
nothing left now Mobius is clearly
scared that if he discovers he had a
good life he'd want to go back to it and
somebody get that man of jety either way
they realized that X5 found selie but
thatd he didn't alert her so she could
keep living her life I don't think that
selie would recognize him either as this
wasn't someone she ran into in season 1
I know most of her life was spent
running from the TVA but I at least they
kept it consistent and also X5 he's kind
of following her footsteps by getting
his own life now he watches Obi goes to
the temporal l which is where we see it
firing up and getting more unstable
anyway that tastes for time just doing
the one so I think that eventually this
is going to overload and potentially
explode causing bigger fractures in the
Multiverse I think that this is what
Sylvia was up to last week with her
probably traveling back with Loki when
she was climbing out of the elevator she
said there you are and therefore I think
a future Loki and syvia teamed up to
return to this moment when the temporal
Loom hits critical mass looking at the
environment when this is happening the
walls and lights were going haywire
which I believe probably links to this I
think the season will be about trying to
fix the temporal Loom which is why they
have to get help from Victor timely all
these scenes show
it's and I think the series will focus
around fixing this to save the multiv
the temporal Aura is also said to be
invalid so they have to find a way to
lock this whole thing down now Loki moi
decide to go back to X5 which is when
they decide to play Things the hard way
it basically turns in a lowkey locking
them in together and busting out a
crushing temporal Doorway to get what he
wants we actually had a little nod to
this last week as you could catch a
poster warning not to get stuck inside
the doorway Loki also says he's wrote a
script of his own I wrote a little
script of my own which goes beyond just
Brad being an actor as we saw with he
who remains he had a stack of paper
showing everything everyone was going to
say but this only went up to a certain
point in in the end both lokis went off
in different directions and are now
creating a script of their own Loki
fully plays into his villainous side
which I think he may need if he's going
to lead the TVA that's kind of how I
think things are going to go with Kang's
Empire literally crumbling around us in
the opening scene of episode one I think
this scene works really well too with
them literally boxing X5 in in order to
get answers watching The Box get smaller
and smaller as the music ramps up it
just builds up so well and in the end it
cranks up the tension so much now as X5
Falls we can also see some scars on his
arms shout outs to Eric at new rockstars
for pointing out last week that this
actually lined up with his armor which
we could see when he was standing with
his gloves around his neck these scars
lined up with a scratch across his armor
showing that they were all likely
created in the same blow now from here
we could to be 15 in KC entering the
temporal Loom I think it was Cosmic
wonder who pointed out first that this
looked like the daughter s BR from X-men
with it possibly being a precursor to
the MCU Vision kiuu he just just
absolutely killed here we going to die
oh hey nice to meet you we going to die
in Casey starts fanboying over OB
writing the TVA handbook if you got out
the credits we actually get a closeup of
this book and can see the see the little
bit that says it's written by orboros
again it shows how important he is to
the organization but we also have to
question why he was completely shoved
out the way Mt was saying that he might
actually be the villain of this series
with him orchestrating the chaos that we
see playing out man was pushed out the
way for inuries and this may even be him
out for Revenge he also brought up how
he could actually be Mr Griffin who in
case you don't know is a Kang variant
Griffin is a shape shifter that can
transform how he looks and he's also had
a nod given to him in the series before
during the opening of episode five we
could see the Avengers Tower had the
name Kang on it which was something that
Mr Griffin owned potentially Obie could
be this and this is why he knows so much
about time travel Obie suggests that
they either get Miss minutes to return
or he finds he who remains is probably
teasing what's going to happen next week
both Kang and Miss minute were the ones
that took his work and used it as a way
to take over everything thus getting
back to them that might be the end game
that eventually leads to him being the
big bad now from here we cut to a branch
timeline in 1982 which is where we saw
Sylvia in the post credit scene last
week they show that she's not been there
a full year and they do a great job of
keeping things in line with McDonald's
in the80s the sign says over 40 billion
served whereas these days it's over 3
300 billion a coworker also
said well you can try our new Chicken
McNugget saying we have a big ma shout
out to Eric Voss for pointing out these
were first introduced in select stores
during 1981 which builds off the back of
them being new we also get along line
with sy's coworker where I feel like it
shows she's aware of everything hey um
can you refill the STW expens when you
get a sick I've already done it this is
kind of like how he remains knew what
was coming before it did or you know it
might be a reach also so I want to
apologize again for having another cold
I keep having these colds yet we've got
twins that they're already Nursery at
the moment and every week they either
bringing home bad reports of viruses
which is nice but I'm pushing it on the
viewers you get to you get to hear the
brunt of it in my snotty nasly voice but
either way this is made her a star
employee as she already has five of them
on her name badge this scene was
actually released by McDonald's earlier
in the air as they're doing a lowkey tye
alongside the show X5 is also super
nervous too let's just get it to go and
we get up and we get out of here is this
a setup which we later learn is Judd
dox's plans I'll explain how this works
later on because you might be wondering
how certain points and timelines can be
wiped out yet still have existed at some
point now on her lunch break Loki lays
it all out and talks about how we saw
her future at the TVA we see how she's
starting to get more in line with how
she looked in the elevator as she's now
got her green coat and hairstyle from
that you can also catch her wearing her
normal boots though showing that she's
still got some of the old syi in there
we can also see she's got an Ang symbol
for her earring pronounce are terribly H
but this actually means it's it
symbolizes life now Sy we found a new
life here and she just wants to be left
alone and be able to live it now Loki
talks to her about our Theory time and
he says that he feels the same way too
however Sylvie says is it really because
that sounds a lot like the future's
already been written and we both know
that it hasn't not anymore and this is
something they discuss a lot in The
Terminator franchise that wrestles back
and forth between fate and free will but
as we know Sylvie will end up there
which to me shows that someone else is
still in charge again I personally think
Loki will take over which was foreshadow
during the opening shot of the season
now X5 desperately wants to get back to
the sacred timeline as that's all that
safe and he's well aware of what's about
to happen clearly jittery Moi plays to
his ego about zc which he passes off as
elevated horror man's making Cinema I
heard some of that a24 is and it's from
1977 so bloody get Martin score sayy on
the phone now but the 70s was of course
a golden ag4 with the excist releasing
in the decade now X5 going wild in the
car park makes her enchant him and we
see dox's plan I love how Sylvie reveals
her costume as well which her changing
her clothes from the McDonald's uniform
steps closer to the future version
entering a giant Hall we see as they
Mass pruning the branches and wiping out
trillions of lives now Doc is still
clearly indoctrinated to the idea of
what the TVA was set up for with her
describing it as a mission our mission
is
compromised set up what you can she also
had War medals on with the eke Keeper's
heads showing she dedicated her life to
this entire facade speaks to me how some
will still continue on with their life
even when they're shown it's wrong and
highlights the Blind Faith that TVA have
in their leaders this idea of Faith was
highlighted in the murals last week with
there being several images that went
towards the idea of religion the the
timekeepers had their hands pressed
together like a prayer and those on the
ground were praising them like gods and
then the timekeepers came along and
saved us
all we really start to get the idea of
the cost here though with the TVA
staring at the Timeline dissipating
destroying countless lives now you might
be wondering how this works when people
will exist in moments before they were
pruned I think it happens the same way
as incursions do in the comics which are
basically when two worlds crash into to
each other there are ways to avert this
by destroying the the world or finding a
way to pass through the Earth still
though hitting this Earth wipes out
everything in it both forwards and
backwards in time as well just like how
pruning a timeline does and that's how
people like Old Man Logan can exist in
the future with his past being a branch
now say they traveled to 2010 and pruned
it from there it would still continue to
wipe things out in the Old Man Logan
future how this works is that it's like
a ripple effect in which the explosion
starts off from the impact point and
then travels forwards and backwards
through time now say someone pruned the
branch wear in now technically you from
yesterday would be wiped out along with
you from today however this would happen
in a ripple effect with you from last
month getting wiped out first then last
week and so on makes you realize how
little time you have left to hit the
thumbs up button but that's how I think
timeline wiping out works now some
timelines survive so we can still have
multiversal stories but large sections
of the Multiverse are completely wiped
out how the Duck movie Gone
morbius fingers crossed for that one and
I'm hoping that the Xmen timeline
survives cuz really like those movies
however I feel like this ending kind of
Echoes the one from episode two in
season 1 in which Sylvie did something
similar she ended up bombing the TVA in
order to try and save countless
timelines Raz here is revers to do the
opposite effect either way Ren slayer's
temp pad is finally tracked and Sylvia
returns to the branch 1982 here we catch
you listening to Cosmic Blues by Janice
choplin which itself has a deeper
meaning performed at Woodstock in 1968
the song starts off with the lyric time
keeps moving this of course reflects
what's going on here but beyond that
it's got another layer to it the song is
about trying to stay optimistic even if
reality constantly lets you down selie
has tried to car about her own life here
but she inevitably has ended up coming
up short though she says to Jack she
thinks she'll be in tomorrow that like
isn't the case as we close out with her
starting up the he who remains device
this is where the power arrives from and
we theorized last season that it was
linked in with the device Tony star
created as the quantum realm GPS that
was something that wrapped around the
front of the hand which is something
that this also does guessing next week
she may jump across time and we could
potentially end up seeing the Victor
timely episode also her promise to Jack
yeah it it might stay true cuz
technically she can time travel and
could still show up at work tomorrow
even after she's gone off and done a big
adventure lots of time you why meet
wibbly wobbly stuff and also huge shout
outs to Scarlet Witch news on Twitter
for spotting in the credits you can see
a post note that says hex moment there's
also a diagram looking like the symbol
on the dark hold so good catch cuz I
completely missed that now as for my
thoughts on this entry I felt it was a
slight step down from last week with it
mainly being set up and reuniting the
characters stuff like that I always feel
is kind of by the numbers cuz you know
they need need to meet back up and they
sort of draw it out so where they really
need to perform is in the execution
which I think again was done brilliantly
throughout Tom Heston really got to come
into his own here and he balanced the
torturing scenes with the more personal
ones brilliantly going from the pi scene
to the torture one worked really well
and helped keep the Dynamics of the
entire show up from there jumping to
McDonald's and then onto the big pruning
scene it just kept it working and made
the episode way better than it could
have been if it if it just just fall
into the Trap of being like yeah we're
going to meet up let's go see them oh
yeah let's go meet up I still don't
think it quite hit the heights of last
week but I'd still say this was a solid
entry even if it wasn't perfect I love
the handheld camera feeling that the
episodes all have and again the
direction and set design is completely
Stellar guessing things are going to
ramp up next week anyway and yet let me
know your thoughts before we get into
the trailer this bit coming up could
contain spoilers and though we're
breaking down the public trailer it may
be stuff you just don't want to know do
me a favor though yeah on the on the way
out hit the like and uh hope sorry I
keep begging that but you know it's been
been a tough day getting this recorded
cuz my my voice is I've just kept losing
it so thanks I'd appreciate it now but
you guys who stayed through that I have
a feeling that Mobius will end up back
at his jet ski place as we saw in the
trailer how Loki arrived at the location
that sells them I'm guessing Mobius
might return back to his life and go
there which is when Loki will go and try
and pull him out did seem like he was is
time slipping again so maybe something
happens with the loom that causes this
to expand I think next time that they're
going to track down Victor timely which
will also take them to where raon Rens
Slayer is this looks like it takes place
at the Chicago fair and remember it was
used as the post credit scene for
Quantum Mania now on stage we could
catch Victor timely showing off the
temporal Loom and thus I think they'll
need him to fix the one in the present
Victor timely is a variant of Kang who
traveled back to the Past after
suffering several defeat in the past he
used his knowledge of the future to
create incredible inventions and he
built a town of timely up around him
Kang's wholeo is that he wants to rule
and no matter what point he travels to
in time that's all he wants to do I
think they might even grab this one from
the stage and take it back with them and
then swap everything out so that the
entire timeline saved this was
potentially what Loki saw Sylvie going
to do and it's possible that timely goes
to the TVA with them there was a shot in
one of the promos where where we could
see a model of the super Mobius war in
episode one with Jonathan majes clearly
being at the end of it so I think
they're possibly bringing it all back to
the TVA where they'll try and replace Al
Loom and yeah fix the entire thing I
think that would be a good way to take
things if Victor timley was a good guy
and it would show how you never know
which version of Kang you're going to
get sometimes you'll bump into a villain
sometimes they'll be good guys and we
might even see some turn from good to
bad I do like the way the show is going
though and you never know what's coming
around around the corner sure there are
these brief things because of where time
travel goes but we will see as we get
into it now please drop a like on the
video and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
they helping us out again we have our
Mitch store just below the video and if
you want to pick up that Loki inspired
t-shirt or the Ahsoka one before we take
it offline then and definitely head over
there right after this without the way
huge thank you is always always for sing
through the video really appreciate it
that you've watched I don't know why you
watching at this point but yeah
hopefully I see you next time and you
you take care yourself mate take care
peace